AS WE'RE LOOKING AT UKRAINE
TRYING TO HOLD THE LAND THAT IT
HAS BEEN ABLE TO CLEAR, THAT IT
HAS TAKEN BACK FROM RUSSIA,
RIGHT NOW THE U.S. IS PROVIDING
WEAPONS FOR MISSILES FOR THE
HIMARS SYSTEMS THAT GO ABOUT 50
MILES.
UKRAINE WOULD OBVIOUSLY LIKE
THEM TO GO FURTHER.
BUT GOING 200 MILES, THE U.S.
SAYS NO.
50 MILES, YES.
WHAT WOULD REACH THAT THRESHOLD
FOR YOU OF SAYING YES TO A
WEAPON THAT WOULD GO 200 MILES?
>> WELL, THE REASON THE
ADMINISTRATION, I THINK, IS
RELUCTANT, WE HAD A BRIEFING ON
THIS YESTERDAY, THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF REASONS, SOME I CAN
SHARE WITH YOU, SOME I CAN'T.
THE REASON IT WOULD CLEARLY BE
AN ESCALATION.
IT WOULD INVITE PUTIN TO TAKE
FURTHER ESCALATORY STEPS.
IN ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION, WHAT
WOULD IT TAKE FOR ME TO SUPPORT
THOSE ADDITIONAL EFFORTS, WOULD
BE IF PUTIN ESCALATES.
HERE'S THE GREAT DANGER.
THE PARADOX OF THE SITUATION
WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW IS THE BETTER
THE UKRAINIANS DO, THE MORE
DANGEROUS PUTIN BECOMES.
THE MORE HE'S BACKED INTO A
CORNER.
AND HE'S GETTING PRESSURE IN
RUSSIA, IF YOU READ THE PRESS,
NOT FROM PEOPLE WHO SAY LET'S
GET THIS OVER WITH, LET'S GET
OUT.
HE'S GETTING PRESSURE FROM
PEOPLE SAYING DO MORE.
AND HIS PATTERN IN ALEPPO, IN
SYRIA, IN GROZNY, IN CHECHNYA,
IS BOMB THE CRAP OUT OF THEM.
CIVILIANS, CARPET BOMB.
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M WORRIED
ABOUT.
I THINK THE MOST LIKELY NEXT
STEP IS FOR PUTIN TO STEP UP
ATTACKS ON CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO THINK ABOUT HOW
WE AND THE UKRAINIANS RESPOND.
THE KREMLIN WITH THE SHIFTING
ITS STRATEGY IN ITS ATTEMPT TO
GAIN BACK MOMENTUM AS UKRAINE
CONTINUES TO MAKE INCREMENTAL
GAINS MORE THAN ONE WEEK AFTER
ITS LIGHTNING-FAST
COUNTEROFFENSIVE IN THE EAST.
RUSSIAN MEDIA ARE REPORTING
MOSCOW BEST SEPARATIST LEADERS
IN THE LUHANSK AND DONETSK
REGIONS ARE CALLING FOR
IMMEDIATE REFERENDUMS ON
JOINING RUSSIA.
THIS COMES ONE DAY AFTER
UKRAINE CLAIMED ITS SOURCES HAD
LIBERATED ANOTHER VILLAGE IN
THE LUHANSK REGION AND
DESTROYED A MILITARY BASE.
STATE MEDIA ALSO REPORTING THE
PRO-RUSSIAN OFFICIALS IN THE
OCCUPIED KHERSON ZAPORIZHZHIA
REGION'S PLAN TO HOLD VOTES ON
WHETHER TO BECOME PART OF
RUSSIA IN THE COMING DAYS AS
WELL.
UKRAINE RESPONDED BY SAYING
THAT THIS IS WHAT THE FEAR OF
DEFEAT LOOKS LIKE AND THAT
REFERENDUMS WILL NOT CHANGE
ANYTHING.
THE LUHANSK REGIONAL GOVERNOR
HAD THIS TO SAY.
>> [INTERPRETER]
ALL THEY CAN DO NOW IS HOLD
REFERENDUMS.
CERTAINLY FAKE ONES WITH SOME
MADE-UP RESULTS.
THEY WOULD DO SO IN ORDER TO
JOIN OCCUPIED TERRITORIES OF
UKRAINE WITH THE RUSSIAN
FEDERATION, SO THEY CAN DO
THINGS LATER ON.
>> RUSSIA'S FORMER PRESIDENT
STATED THAT IF THE BREAKAWAY
REGIONS DECIDE TO JOIN RUSSIA,
IT WILL ALLOW MOSCOW TO USE ITS
FULL MILITARY CAPABILITY IN THE
DONBAS REGION.
THEY PLAN TO ESCALATE THIS
ISSUE EVEN FURTHER.
WE ARE JOINED NOW FROM KHARKIV.
LET'S GET YOUR TAKE ON THIS,
THE IDEA THAT RUSSIA AND
OCCUPIED AREAS ARE HOLDING SHAM
REFERENDUMS OF JOINING RUSSIA.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY ABOUT
PUTIN'S STRATEGY?
AND WALK US THROUGH MORE OF THE
UKRAINIAN REACTION HERE.
>> I THINK WHAT IT SAYS IS THIS
IS HIS NEXT MOVE FOLLOWING MUCH
OF THE KHARKIV REGION IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS OF SEPTEMBER.
THIS COULD POSSIBLY CHANGE THE
ENTIRE LANDSCAPE OF THIS
CONFLICT, BECAUSE FOR INSTANCE,
THE DONETSK AND LUHANSK PEOPLES
REPUBLIC, THESE BREAKAWAY
REPUBLICS THAT DECLARED THEIR
INDEPENDENCE IN 2014.
BY VOTING IN FAVOR OF THESE
REFERENDA TO JOIN RUSSIA, IT
WOULD ESSENTIALLY MEAN AT THESE
AREAS, AS FAR AS RUSSIA IS
CONCERNED, WOULD BECOME PART OF
THE RUSSIAN FEDERATION.
AND THEREFORE, THE WAR THAT IS
GOING ON IN THOSE AREAS WILL BE
A WAR INSIDE, AS FAR AS MOSCOW
IS CONCERNED, A RUSSIAN
TERRITORY.
AND IF IT'S A WAR, IT NO LONGER
WILL BE --
THAT BRINGS IN ALL SORTS OF
POTENTIALITIES.
LIKE, FOR INSTANCE, MASS
MILITARY CONSCRIPTION.
AND PERHAPS THE USE OF THE KIND
OF WEAPONRY THAT MOSCOW HAS
BEEN HOLDING BACK IN THIS
CONFLICT.
AND AT THIS POINT, I DON'T
THINK THERE IS MUCH QUESTION
ABOUT THE POSSIBLE OUTCOME OF
THESE REFERENDA, WHICH WILL BE
HELD BETWEEN THE --
KEEP IN MIND THAT IN 2014, WHEN
RUSSIAN FORCES ENTERED CRIMEA,
THERE WAS A REFERENDUM SHORTLY
THEREAFTER.
AND 97%, ACCORDING TO THE
RUSSIAN AUTHORITIES, VOTED IN
FAVOR OF JOINING THE RUSSIAN
FEDERATION.
I WAS THERE IN CRIMEA AT THE
TIME, AND IT WAS OBVIOUS THAT
NOT EVERYONE, CERTAINLY NOT 97%
OF THE POPULATION, WAS IN FAVOR
OF JOINING RUSSIA.
BUT THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED AND
WE COULD VERY WELL SEE A REPEAT
IN THESE FOUR REGIONS.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT MUSEUM.
JUST EXPLAIN TO US THE SORT OF
NIGHTMARISH EXPERIENCE AND THE
TRAUMA IN TERMS OF WHAT PEOPLE
IN IZIUM HAVE BEEN LIVING WITH
AS A RESULT OF RUSSIAN
OCCUPATION.
>> FOR THE FIRST FEW MONTHS OF
THE WAR, IS IAN THROUGH WHICH A
RIVER FLOWS, WAS DIVIDED
BETWEEN ONE SIDE OF THE RIVER
WAS UKRAINIAN FORCES, AND THE
OTHER SIDE WAS RUSSIAN FORCES.
IT WAS A VICIOUS BATTLE OF
THEIR.
THE CITY, PARTS OF IT ARE
ABSOLUTELY DESTROYED.
AND THEN WHEN THE RUSSIANS TOOK
OVER IN THE SPRING, THEY
INSTITUTED THE REIGN OF --
I WOULDN'T CALL IT TERROR, BUT
CERTAINLY THE CHAOS.
PEOPLE TOLD US THEY WERE AFRAID
TO GO OUT INTO THE STREET AND
VERY LITTLE WAS PROVIDED IN
TERMS OF BASIC SERVICES OR
FOOD.
WE SPOKE TO ONE WOMAN, 85 YEARS
OLD, WHO HAD A STROKE BUT NEVER
RECEIVED ANY MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE.
PEOPLE ARE HAPPY WITH THE
RUSSIANS WHO ARE GONE.
IT IS A STRUGGLE IN IZIUM.
>> HELP ARRIVES IN IZIUM, BANKS
OF BARLEY MEAL.
WAITING HER TURN, SHE STRUGGLED
--
>> WE SURVIVED WORLD WAR II
WHEN I WAS LITTLE, SHE TELLS
ME.
SHE HANDS OUT MEDICINE,
SEDATIVE'S ARE IN HIGH DEMAND.
>> HALF OF A YEAR, SIX MONTHS
WITHOUT ANY HELP.
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT DO --
JUST IMAGINE, WHAT DO THEY FEEL?
>> LIBERATION FROM RUSSIA IS IN
THE END OF IZYUM'S STRUGGLES.
MUCH OF THE CITY WAS SEVERELY
BOMBARDED BEFORE FALLING IN
SPRING TO THE RUSSIANS.
THERE IS NO RUNNING WATER, NO
ELECTRICITY, NO HEAT.
CROWDS GATHERED TO GET CELL
PHONES OFF ARMY GENERATOR, TEN
MINUTES PER PERSON.
USING INTERNET PROVIDED BY A
SATELLITE CONNECTION.
LUBOV ENTER DAUGHTER ANGELA ARE
CALLING RELATIVES.
THEY WANT TO LEAVE.
WINTER IS COMING.
>> PEOPLE WILL FREEZE, ANGELA
WARNS.
OLDER PEOPLE WON'T SURVIVE.
THEY ALSO FEAR THE RUSSIANS
COULD RETURN.
NEARBY, SIGNS OF THEIR HASTY
RETREAT.
HELMETS STREWN OUTSIDE A HOUSE
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS COMMANDEERED.
BREAD CRUMBS STILL ON THE TABLE,
INSECTS GETTING AT THE FRUIT
THAT HAS NOT BEEN EATEN.
ON THE EDGE OF TOWN REMAINS
RUSHES ONCE VAUNTED ARMY,
BEFORE A MONUMENT HARKING BACK
TO DIFFERENT TIMES WHICH NOW
SEEMS LIKE THE DISTANT PAST.
NATASHA SHOWS ME A NEWSPAPER
DISTRIBUTED DURING THE
OCCUPATION.
>> WHAT DOES SHE THINK OF HIM?
>> [INTERPRETER]
I HAVEN'T THOUGHT ANYTHING GOOD
ABOUT HIM SINCE 2000, SHE SAYS.
HE DESTROYED EVERYTHING IN
RUSSIA.
THE PAPER DOES, HOWEVER, COME
IN HANDY.
>> PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY HAS SAID
THE GOVERNMENT WILL DO ALL IT
CAN TO RESTORE THE BASIC
SERVICES AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE.
BECAUSE GOING THROUGH THE
WINTER IN THIS PART OF UKRAINE
WITHOUT HEATING WILL BE VERY
DIFFICULT.
RECONSTRUCTING THE CITY IS
GOING TO BE MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT.